[Music]
this morning we're gonna start off this
this day of content by talking about
I should get my clicker here by talking
about best practices best practices we
all love best practices is the wisdom
accumulated from long and varied
experience best practices helped us get
things done safely efficiently and
effectively much of what we talk about
in a conference like this is best
practices let me take web apps for
example many perhaps even most of our
web apps today look something like this
right you have kind of a standard
three-tier design a front-end JavaScript
mobile app what have you talks
HTTP probably rests to a back-end you
have workers that are probably stateless
and they talked to a database that's a
separate separate tier database now
there's a lot of benefits to writing
your apps this way to design your apps
in a standardized way some some of them
are obvious but one of them is when it
comes to deployment your app will fit
well right your app fits well with the
tools in the ecosystem you fit well with
kubernetes you fit well with serverless
your app fits into the cloud ecosystem
and all you so you have all these
resources available to help you deploy
scale secure manage your app if it's a
conventional three-tier stateless app if
it follows those best practices so best
practices very important in this session
we're gonna throw those best practices
away we're gonna talk about those times
when you just have to chuck the best
practices we need to push the boundaries
and break out of our content
because we need to create the next new
thing so of course when you do that when
you do that when you break convention
you start to lose that fit right you
start to lose that fit tests like
deployment integration with other
systems become more challenging I'm
gonna tell you about an app that I
worked on where it didn't follow a lot
of those conventions that were used to
I'll talk about the journey that I took
to make it work make it fit in the cloud
we'll talk about some other platforms
that don't follow conventional cloud
practices and how they're adapting to
the cloud and we'll talk about how your
unconventional apps some things that you
can do to make them fit in the cloud now
of course this is not gonna be a like an
exhaustive survey of all the different
things that you can do I mean there's
there's just no way right we're going to
focus on just a couple of examples a
couple of ways that apps sometimes break
the mold and the techniques that we're
gonna discuss here are also not the that
they're not the end zombie though
they're not the final say here they may
work well for some apps they may be a
terrible idea for others so rather the
goal here is to take a look at some
examples take a look at some examples
just get some ideas flowing so that's a
your your creativity can get unlocked so
as you are faced with deploying your
unique app with its unique challenges
you have a starting point you have kind
of a starting point stew and some ideas
that can stimulate your own thinking
okay so quick introduction before I get
too far my name is Daniel I work at
Google as an engineer on the Ruby team
any Ruby developers here Ruby okay a few
of you I work for you my job is to make
the cloud better for rubyists my team
works on API claw
runtimes for App Engine developer tools
tutorials documentation basically
everything that you need in order to
make the cloud work for Rubeus for you
as Ruby developers and we're part of a
group of teams that focus on different
programming language communities so I
work on Ruby I also do some work on the
elixir programming language any elixir
developers here by the way
one Oh awesome how about Erlang Earling
is another related language any Erlanger
's No oh great great you guys do
anything on google cloud with the lick
sir underlying starting to great yeah so
so you know we're doing a little bit's
with Erlang now and a little bit of
elixir it's a lot of fun I you know
i-i've been learning elixir myself for
the past four years or so but for the
rest of us we have an opportunity now to
learn something new so that's great
elixir and Erlang are both closely
related languages they're both
functional programming languages they
both target a platform called OTP OTP
actually OTP is part of the platform
there's a bunch of related components
there is a VM there is an runtime system
OTP relates to the library the standard
library and frameworks associated with
the platform but it's a really
interesting platform for web development
it has powerful features around
concurrency and around distributed
systems and it also has some really
interesting features around fault
tolerance and error recovery but on the
flip side Erlang an OTP the architecture
of an app written for this platform can
be different from the way that we're
used to writing writing web apps in
other languages like nodejs or ruby or
go or anything else and this difference
is something that I first encountered
when I was first learning a lick sir I
had joined a study group
with some friends from a local meetup
this is about four years ago and we did
a book study in the study group and then
four of us got together and we said you
know let's put some of the things that
we've learned into practice
and do a project together so we did this
project this is a screenshot of what we
built as you can see it's a simple
multiplayer tank game we wrote it as a
web app and you've probably seen this
sort of thing before you drive a tank
around a maze you have other players
that are online with you and they're
driving around tanks you try to shoot
them down
so it's online it's multiplayer it's
real-time now none of us were
professional game developers right this
is the first time that we've done
something like this and we're trying to
learn that at the same time we're
learning elixir so it was it was a lot
of fun it was a challenge but we had to
figure out a bunch of things while we
were doing this right and in particular
we learned that doing this kind of thing
as a web app presents some challenges we
figured out early on that the game logic
you know keeping the game state tracking
the objects on the on the screen doing
collision detection all that stuff it
has to be run over here on the server
side because we have multiple players
multiple clients connected so we need
some central source of truth for what's
going on so that means we have to stream
updates across to the clients so this is
an action game this is a real-time game
we want 20 30 frames per second so rest
requests HTTP not gonna work too much
latency
so we changed that to a WebSocket right
and in general we started to tinker with
this web app architecture we started to
change things around because of you know
what our use case was what our
requirements were we looked at the game
logic itself and we realized okay this
is a long-running game simulation that
we're run
here this is a background process that's
continually updating the game stage
frame-by-frame and so it has to operate
pretty rapidly again 20 30 frames per
second so if the game state is kept in a
separate database again probably too
much latency so we chucked the database
and instead we kept the game states in
memory in our back-end servers so now
imagine we've got this game simulation
running on one of those servers say this
one no there's no guarantee that it's
the same server that all the players
WebSockets are connected to right you
know the load balancer is just going to
connect a client to whatever it
connected to so we were thinking ok how
do we deal with this and there are a few
ways you can bypass the load balancer
you can customize the load balancer or
you can let the server's talk to each
other make our serve back-end service
parts of an interconnected cluster and
so that they can forward messages back
and forth to wherever they need to be so
again we were tinkering with the app
architecture tinkering with it and we
ended up landing on something that looks
kind of like this let me say yeah okay
this will work this will work this this
will work for our tag game and turns out
that elixir and OTP supports this kind
of architecture quite well they have
stateful processes state kept in memory
there are nodes that inter can that's
are interconnected that can forward
messages back and forth to each other
this kind of real-time distributed
system is the kind of thing that elixir
that OTP are particularly designed for
so as we were learning OTP as we were
learning elixir this is how we ended up
designing our app so a little bit
unconventional compared with most web
apps so all this is going well we had
our game it was working it was playable
we were having fun the
of us and we decided okay let's demo it
to our meetup group so let's let's get
the whole meetup group together and you
know they could all connect up and we
can play the game together and we can
show them how how it works how we
developed it so that was a great plan
that we had to decide how we were going
to deploy the game so that people could
connect connect up to it well this was
2015 four years ago and this is a time
that saw the emergence of a really
interesting deployment technology
kubernetes was interesting and important
at the time it came out because of the
way that it oriented the industry around
container practices the way that it's
codified the practices of container
based deployments technically kubernetes
is a very flexible system and we'll talk
a little bit about that a little later
but in practice its usage is actually
pretty opinionated conventionally
kubernetes wants your servers to be
stateless no not stateful and wants them
to be transient and not persistent it
wants them to be independent and not
interconnected this didn't match the way
that our app was designed right you have
yeah you have kubernetes stateful says
also they were called pet sets at the
time but even those didn't quite fit
with what we were trying to do we were
keeping States in memory as these
long-running processes so when we tried
to deploy our tank game using kubernetes
we ran afoul of some of these opinions
and at the time we said
I was just punt on this we just wanted
to get something working for our meetups
so we punted on it but it does bring up
a very interesting and important
question and it's something that's we
eventually came back to when we just
when we started thinking about you know
how how would we really deploy this if
it were a production application we
started asking ourselves is kubernetes
even though it's embodying what's now
kind of becoming cloud best practices is
kubernetes just not the right technology
for deploying an app like this our
containers just not the right technology
is the cloud itself Pfau best practices
just not designs for apps like this and
we were not alone in a scheme some of
these questions the elixir an OTP
community as a whole has been debating
this quite a bit over the past few years
there's a feeling that containers and
conventional cloud practices just don't
fit with the way that our apps look
because of this the OTP community has
been kind of slow in adopting the cloud
so later when we came back to this
question we started thinking okay you
know we want if we wanted to deploy this
to say kubernetes engine what would we
do what what should we do when our app
breaks the rules when our platform
breaks the rules
can it be done can i deploy this to gke
and actually have it work reasonably
well so let's take a closer look at this
app and where where does it not fit
where does not fit with the cloud what
can we do about it
well first the workers in our app are
interconnected right they form a cluster
and they have to talk to each other
so now of course no more kubernetes
practice is for replicas to be
independent right but let's set normal
practice aside for the moment if your
workers need to inter communicate what
does that mean practically that means
they need to know where each other are
you know they need to know how to reach
each other they need to have each
other's I P addresses and the
credentials that they need to talk to
each other there are ways to get that
sort of information
most of us treat kubernetes as a
deployment tool but really is first and
foremost an API right it's an API that
you can use to build deployment tools to
build ops tools it provides all sorts of
useful information about the shape of
your deployment and you can talk to this
API from within your app so that might
look something like this this is elixir
codes it's adapted from our tank games
so don't worry about the details here I
just want to point out a couple of
things kubernetes provides you with your
pods service account credentials the
credentials you need to talk to other
things in the kubernetes cluster in the
kubernetes ecosystem these are available
in the file system so we're setting the
path to those credentials here as a
Constance kubernetes dns also provides
the domain name the exposes.the domain
name for itself for its own API endpoint
so we're setting that Constance and we
can use that information we have
everything we need to send requests to
the kubernetes api from within your app
so this code for example it returns a
list of the IP addresses for all the
pods in yours
so once you have those addresses pods
can reach each other so what if as each
pod in your kubernetes deployment spins
up as each container spins up we ran
that code during initialization we
contact the kubernetes api we get a list
of all the other pods running a list of
IP addresses and then we can use that to
establish any connections that we need
to add that new worker to the cluster
right we run all that during
initialization now when a worker is
shutting down we want to remove it from
the cluster so we might need to do some
disconnection some cleanup and again you
can use tools that kubernetes gives you
such as lifecycle hooks how many of you
already familiar with this you can
configure your pods and your containers
with your pods with a pre stop hook that
gets executed when that pot is
terminated
you can also trap the term signal that
sense to your container when it gets
terminated so you have these
initialization and these shutdown hooks
available and they can enable your app
to maintain an interconnected cluster
like our tank game needed okay this is a
pretty common use case for elixir
developers so the community has
developed a library for it but even if
you're not an elixir developer I know
most of us are not if your app needs
information about its own deployment
environments just a little digging into
the kubernetes api can will yield a lot
of useful information all right so far
pretty straightforward
what else is our app doing differently
well our workers are hosting these
long-running processes these
long-running game simulations that keep
States not only keep state they're not
just stateful processes but they're
keeping state in memory so why is this
an issue
well most normal deployment practices
assume that you can bring down a
container at any time right you can
bring down a worker at any time they
assume that backends are transient they
assume backends are stateless and we're
breaking those rules because we're
running these games simulations in
memory and so when kubernetes wants to
take down that container say wants to
scale down and wants to do a rolling
updates we have a problem unless unless
what if there was a way to move that
running game to a different worker this
is a technique known as process
migration moving processes or states
from one node to another in the
distributed system in general maybe
within a cluster of workers within
fibrin Eddie's there are a number of
different forms of process migration
there's been a lot of research done into
it over the years but in our case it's
fairly simple fairly straightforward
first thing you need to do is you need
to be able to checkpoint a process you
need to be able to pause it you need to
capture its state and serialize it now
for a game simulation conceptually this
is not not that difficult your process
is just this long-running process that's
updating the game world frame by frame
so you just need to capture one of those
frames capture that as a big data
structure no TP actually provides you
with a number of tools that's that help
with that capturing managing serializing
states so next thing is you need to be
able to move that state elsewhere and
continue running the process one
straightforward way to do that is to use
a message queuing service so when a node
is about to go down remember we have
those kubernetes shutdown hooks right so
we use that you pause the game pause any
games there might be multiple games
running on that node we serialize their
state and then we push them up to the
queue
then some other node in the cluster can
pull those date games down from the
queue and resume running them so now
we've effectively moved that game from
one node to another node there and there
of course a number of queueing systems
available for you can free to use those
RabbitMQ there's Apache Kafka if you're
using Google clouds you might just use
Google cloud pub/sub and here's what
that would look like you create one
topic for process migration you use a
single shared subscription for all the
running nodes to listen to and when the
container is about to go down
you serialize games publish those game
States up to that pub subtopic each of
those games will then get pulled down by
one of the other nodes that's listening
in on that subscription since we have a
single shared subscription it will
distribute games among all the listening
that all the listeners so if you want to
implement a system like this pub/sub
might be a reasonable way to do it there
are a few things to watch for some
things that so we encountered if you're
familiar with process migration in
general you probably know that one of
the big challenges is maintaining
communication maintaining communication
if you have a communication channel with
a process say you're a player connected
to a running game and that game moves to
a different node what do you do alright
how do you reconnect to that game how do
you find the new locations for that
process one way to handle this is to
create and maintain a kind of address
book mapping from a process ID or a name
or some kind of identifier for that
process for that game say to the
location where it can be found in the
lick sir OTP this is known as this
handle by a construct known as a
registry
so so that's something that we use for
the for our tank game you could use a
low latency database like Redis you
could use some distributed state
mechanism like a CR DT anything that you
can use as a shared consistent source of
truth so keep an address book so that
you can forward messages so that you can
reconnect anything that needs to talk to
those processes that are moving another
issue to consider is load balancing if
you use google cloud pub/sub for example
it'll approximately load balance across
the listeners that are listening in on
this shared subscription but there
aren't guarantees here so if you want
more control or if you maybe you need to
distribute load based on the actual CPU
load on those workers so probably be a
good idea to do something like
monitoring load you can use a product
like sector of your monitoring there are
third-party solutions for that sort of
thing based on that information then you
can selectively enable or disable
listeners or you can send Mac's as
necessary some other queueing system is
also have some interesting features that
can be helpful for something like this
if you're using rabbitmq for example
subscribers can specify a priority so
you can set a priority based on say the
load on your worker ok one another item
depending on the queuing system that
you're using it might be possible under
rare conditions for a message to get
delivered more than once this is
possible under Google cloud pub/sub
sometimes possible under other queueing
systems so you might need a mechanism to
detect and resolve this case and that's
another case where a process registry
can help because it's a shared source of
truth of it's just for where process
needs to be running then you can use
that to resolve who wins if multiple
workers try to pull down a process
so just a few considerations to to be
aware of all right
so we've talked about queuing systems as
a way to due process migration and
they're a common way for process
migration but they're not the only way
our tank game was written in OTP in the
lick sir and that ecosystem actually has
access to a lot of really interesting
tools for writing distributed
applications distributed systems you
could take advantage of tools in the
platform that you're writing for the
ecosystem to build process migration
directly so this is actually what we
ended up doing we we wrote our own
process migration in the lexer and it
turns out that there are some nice
libraries available in the ecosystem as
open source that did most of what we
needed to do so again most of us aren't
illiterate developers here so I won't go
down that rabbit hole describing all of
that if you are interested in a deeper
dive in some of the things that you can
do you can look for this talk but I did
a lecture kampf last year it's on
YouTube but in general there are
multiple ways that you can implement
something like this and there are some
trade-offs of course between different
implementations there are performance
versus complexity trade-offs one of the
reasons we rolled our own and did that
within the the elixir ecosystem we pass
messages back and forth as OTP messages
and one of the reasons we did that was
performance we actually got really
really incredible performance out of
that but it did mean that we had to do
some custom code so there are some
trade-offs there are reliability
concerns security considerations that
you might need to think about so you'll
need to vet those concerns for your app
depending on your particular use case
but in general for a tank game we found
process migration really interesting
it's a really interesting thing because
it actually let us have it both ways let
us have it both ways it let us build an
unconventional app it has a stateful
backends processes in memory all the
performance and interactivity benefits
that came with it and and let us deploy
that with conventional cloud practices
with conventional kubernetes and we got
all the auto scaling all the CI CD
benefits all the cloud kind of
management and ops benefits that come
with that we got it both ways so it was
a really interesting exercise for us and
we learned quite a bit of course it is
possible that process migration in
particular is not appropriate for your
app you know some workloads might not
lend themselves to pausing a running
process snapshotting and serializing or
performance might be an issue you know
for our tank game we got really good
performance out of it maybe a few tens
of milliseconds in order to migrate a
game so it's totally fine for our
application you know people's internet
connections will lag for more than that
but maybe your app has more stringent
real time requirements so let's take a
look at some other ways that you can
deal with things like this with
in-memory states now if you're working
on a large scale say multiplayer gaming
system professional gaming systems often
divide servers into separate pools you
have a set of servers maybe that are for
normal web like requests so things like
profile pages lobbies and so forth and
these can be managed and deployed with
familiar techniques right like
kubernetes but maybe game simulations
maybe you need to do you know games like
as
move long running long running
background processes states in memory
and maybe those things can't be
interrupted so you might want to run
those on a separate pool of servers that
are orchestrated differently so if you
have some servers that follow a
different set of rules can you deal with
that what can you do about that well
fortunately as we mentioned before
kubernetes is a highly flexible system
it has opinions but it can be customized
to implement different sets of rules
even within kind of the same overall
deployments Agony's is a project that
has taken advantage of that some of you
have have heard about this we've talked
about talked about it in some of the
other sessions it provides tools to
manage dedicated game servers
matchmaking some of the various needs of
a gaming system is the deployed is being
developed jointly by Google Cloud and
Ubisoft which is a large game developer
so it's well we're checking out if
you're interested in working in high
performance gaming or anything else that
might be really you know the similar
sorry ok let's take a look at one more
example one of the more interesting
features of elixir and OTP is hot code
upgrade hot code upgrade the OTP
platform actually has the ability to hot
upgrade your code quality running you
can have a code base running code and
then it can seamlessly translate to a
new code base while that code is running
that seemed far-fetched why would you
ever need to do something like that
well Hut code upgrade comes from
OTPs roots as a telecom platform was
originally developed by Erlang back in
the ad R by Ericsson back in the 80s
they developed the Erlang language and
the OTP platform they developed it for
things like applications like switches
say you have a switch that's in the
middle of running live phone calls you
have software running on that switch you
can you can upgrade if you want to
upgrade the software on that switch
while those calls are running you don't
want to disconnect your customers you
don't want to interrupt those phone
calls so so capabilities like hot code
upgrades were developed during this time
and it's a really powerful capability
but it does seem to be kind of contrary
to what we usually do in the cloud right
we kill old containers and we spin up
new ones so what if you wanted to use
something like hot code upgrade in the
cloud what if you you know it's seemed
appropriate for your app and there are
apps that's good good to take advantage
of something like this well here's how
one service is solving this problem
Jake elixir is a platform as a service
it was designed especially with elixir
and OTP applications in mind it's not a
Google product but it has some really
interesting ideas they realize that
containers and kind of conventional
cloud practices
registration is still valuable still
usable for managing your cloud resources
and for doing things like updating
libraries updating your OS updating your
dependencies but containers don't work
so well for hot upgrade no for updating
software in place so jig elixir
developed a hybrid approach and it looks
kind of like this in traditional
deployment you might build you create a
build of your app in docker right so you
have all the dependencies the OS and
your app all in a single docker image
and this is what you deploy to
kubernetes to cloud run for example now
jig elixir modifies this they separate
your app from the OS and dependencies so
they still build the OS and dependencies
in docker but the app is built as a
separate image it gets mounted into the
container as a volume so since your app
lives on a separate volume it has the
ability to modify itself on that volume
even though it's running in the
container so now we can perform hot code
upgrade without taking down that
container then of course if we want to
make these larger but less frequent
changes to the OS or the dependency
layer these can be done using familiar
kubernetes techniques so again a hybrid
approach hybrid approach this is just
another way that a service is found
creative ways to meet the needs of
unconventional apps while continuing to
fit into kind of a cloud ecosystem all
right what have we learned here what
have we learned
well we've seen just a few just a few
techniques that might be useful for
deploying unconventional apps
particularly stateful apps real time
interactive apps we saw that you can use
the kubernetes api to query your
deployments environments we saw that we
how we can use that information to
establish communication among your
server replicas
so if your server replicas needs to for
messages to each other we saw some ways
that you can use process migration to
preserve server-side States even to
preserve running server-side processes
when you resupply your backends we saw
how some projects are extending this the
kubernetes infrastructure and others are
using hybrid techniques to meet the
needs of highly interactive apps in
general we've seen that you don't need
to throw away our tools and our best
practices right often we just need to
stretch them a bit we just need to add
to them a little bit and this is
important it's important to think in
terms of stretching is this process of
stretching our practices that could be
the basis of the next generation of our
cloud tools and our cloud deployment
practices and maybe maybe even the
evolution of the cloud itself I mean
take service for example there's a lot
of talk about service these days right a
lot of talk a lot of excitements maybe
subscripting ism today serverless is
often equated with functions as a
service now functions are awesome for
some workloads some workloads but I mean
let's be real won't work for our tank
game all right
the functions are not the end all and be
all of service and we've seen that we've
seen that during this conference and
cloud run cloud run expands what's
possible under the umbrella of server
lists this expands it beyond functions
just functions per se just a bit just a
bit what if we were to take that a
little bit further what if we were to
imagine the future server lists where we
could even have stateful processes
coexisting with stateless functions
could that look like
what should it look like would his
support process migration support Game
Servers with his support hot code
upgrade this look totally different
maybe would be a terrible idea I don't
know I don't think anyone knows yet but
I think that's the fun part it's the fun
part of where we're at right now in
cloud and it's the kind of question that
can and can and should be driven by our
unconventional apps by apps like our
tank game by apps that you are
developing today that's why I love being
around technologies like elixir like OTP
in the communities that are around those
developers like you who are pushing the
envelope who understands that it's okay
sometimes to be unconventional because
you are the ones catalyzing those
changes the next generation in cloud
coming up with the wild ideas stretching
our best practices and creating more
powerful tools and moving the industry
forward right because we know that
what's conventional today might not be
adequate for tomorrow so here we've
talked about just a few ideas just a few
techniques that might be useful or at
least maybe interesting maybe I'm sure
you have your own ideas that's the point
here I encourage you to come up with
your own ideas to share them get
involved this is your cloud this is your
cloud here this is your community I want
to hear your ideas your colleagues here
want to hear your ideas Google wants to
hear your ideas you know what will
things look like beyond that horizon
let's move the cloud forward together
thank you for coming
[Music]